bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de kiosques que ce que
votre magazine culturel sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 4
novembre
benoît est beau duo d'artistes peintre
franco chinois sont en plateau pour nous
présenter jardin des mots et des mères
une exposition qui met le numérique à la
peinture présente à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt jusqu'au 29
novembre
jean-philippe pelus adjoint au maire
chargé de la culture à bois d'arcy nous
rejoindre en plateau pour nous inviter
au lancement de la première édition du
festival de la bande annonce le 7
novembre
retour sur le spectacle notre peur de
n'être de fabrice mon chien avec en
plateau vladimir steyer assistant
metteur en scène un spectacle qui
questionne l'expression de la solitude
de l'homme moderne
à l'ère du virtuel tout de suite place à
nos premiers invités
bonsoir benoît et bonsoir beau alors je
disais votre duo en fait vous êtes
rencontrés en 2002 et le duo benoit plus
beaux s'est formé en 2005
expliquez-nous comment a eu lieu votre
première rencontre
c'est tout simple j'étais parti en chine
pour un voyage où j'expose et moi même
mon travail et puis j'ai trouvé un
travail en chine travaille plus
alimentaire ou gérants dans une école
d'art où j'ai rencontré beaux qu'ils
étaient étudiants dans l'école d'art en
chine et donc à partir de là vous avez
décidé de commencer à peindre à 80 c'est
ça pas tout de suite on a commencé à
faire des photos ensemble une série de
photos et benoît venait d'arriver en
chine c'est un monde qui lui était
complètement étrangère étrangers et donc
j'ai lu c'est un voeu en quelque sorte
de guide et ensuite petit à petit notre
travail s'étend à la peinture à la halle
à la culture et aux autres médias
ensuite vous avez démarré de la photo en
passant par la teinte
vous présentez donc actuellement une
exposition à la commanderie des
templiers qui s'appelle jardin des 11 et
des mères jusqu'au 29 novembre et alors
là en fait on voit bien les toiles de
base que vous avez ensemble puis une
vous les avez vous travaillé sur
ordinateur expliqué nous un peu votre
travail benoît donc entre commence par
faire un dessin ou une peinture en
choisissant un thème chacun cela on a
choisi on avait choisi un thème sur
fukushima qui nous avait beaucoup marqué
quand on est en chine l'explosion de
fukushima et on retravaille cette
peinture par ordinateur pour la
transformer en quelque chose de
différent puisque c'est de l'art
numérique sts dire un art qui est plus
peut-être plus précis qui est plus froid
aussi parce qu'on passe par la machine
numérique de l'ordinateur mais qui c'est
pour montrer aux gens on sait que le
peut-être le départ d'une idée passe par
la main à la main toujours très utile le
cerveau de relier directement la main
lors de votre travail sur ordinateur
pourquoi ce besoin ou cette envie parce
que les moyens numériques informatiques
numériques et saint jean est un
formidable ça nous permet de renvoyer
par exemple adossé à l'autre bout du
monde et de manière très simple et ça
nous permet de travailler à
l'international de manière beaucoup plus
facile d'être un petit peu partout et
puis c'est un travail c'est un moyen
indépendant et c'est pas les mêmes
effets que la peinture traditionnelle
donc c'était aussi une tentative de déco
de découvrir d'explorer les autres
moyens d'expression que les moyens
conventionnels ne peuvent pas apporter
et c'est un moyen du cou qui permet
également de partager votre art avec le
plus grand nombre
est ce que l'un et l'autre dans votre
travail vous avez dû apporter chacun vos
techniques vos symboles je crois que
vous étiez particulièrement sensible à
la mythologie chinoise
oui c'est ma culture je suis né
ben j'ai grandi là bas et donc forcément
c'est des choses qui sont parlants pour
moi et j'ai utilisent et qui sont petit
à petit devenu parlant pour benoît aussi
et on utilise beaucoup on s'intéresse
beaucoup à l'art numérique à l'art
populaire en chine et c'est un monde de
couleurs vif et qu'il intéresse beaucoup
oui où il ya beaucoup de formes animales
un peu des chimères tous beaucoup de
légendes un peu extraordinaire ville des
pouvoirs magiques c'est un monde assez
chamanique vous comment lâcher votre
bien d'ailleurs sur sur vos tableaux des
couleurs très vives vous parlez des
chimères à chaque fois on retrouve les
dragons cet univers presque onirique est
ce qu on pourrait le dire oui presque
onirique où met on peut retrouver ça
dans l'art du moyen-âge ici aussi un
quasi caire oui donc on ne pas très loin
finalement de l'imaginaire chinois alors
tout à l'heure je vous qualifié
d'artiste peintre
mais vu pour vous passer par ce médium
en fait informatique
est-ce qu'on peut toujours s'en tenir
aux qualificatifs d'artistes peintres ou
ça ne suffit pas bon se présente plutôt
comme artiste visuel parce qu'en touche
beaucoup de supports différents pas que
la peinture mais la base comme la
peinture occupe une place très
importante de notre train dans notre
travail
mais au fond ce qu'on fait c'est des
images mais qu'on est des artistes
visuels
alors vous exposez donc vous proposez
votre travail à la commanderie des
templiers
mais vous êtes artiste en résidence
également à la commanderie jusqu'en juin
quels sont les temps forts de votre
résidence est ce que vous allez partager
des ateliers avec les enfants
exactement donc on nous sommes en train
d'animer une série d'ateliers avec
l'école gagarine et on va aussi
travailler avec les autres structures de
la région et le probablement on va
participer aussi à la nuit des musées en
déjà annoncé ça et puis d'autres a
reconstruit on sera très présente en
région avec les enfants c'est très
important pour nous aussi de transmettre
un peu tout ce qu'on a vécu ses enfants
aussi de leur montrer que l'art
numérique s'est pas seulement qui s'est
pas seulement des jeux vidéo comme peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec un
ordinateur et pass illimité allez sur
youtube ou sur sur internet pour
rechercher des images on peut en créer
facilement le premier temps fort c'est
l'exposition qui en cours qui se termine
le 29 novembre
et puis il y aura des ateliers grand
public
ouvert il faut suivre pour aller sur le
site pourrait poindre et schémas l'agent
tous les ateliers ne sont pas vu encore
fini ouais encore des possibilités aubry
tant qu il a sur ce salon est ouvert à
toutes heures d'atelier on a déjà on en
a déjà fait pas mal en chine tandis nos
habitués en chine donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on aime bien faire c'est un peu
une idée de transmettre transmettre une
technique et un imaginaire
alors benoît revault merci de nous avoir
rejoints sur ce plateau aujourd'hui je
rappelle que l'on pourra retrouver votre
exposition jardins démons et les maires
à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt jusqu'au 29 novembre
on poursuit notre émission avec une
autre résidence artistique celle de
l'ensemble janequin à la merise de
trappes pour la reprise de leur
spectacle d'annie vous pourrez les
retrouver sur scène le samedi 7 novembre
à 20h30 à trappes loufoque décalé et
joyeuse ziani est la dernière création
artistique de l'ensemble clément
janequin formé depuis 37 ans ils
répètent actuellement à la merise de
trappes
ce spectacle fidèle à l'esprit de la
troupe
les tire son nom d'un compositeur de la
première moitié du xvième siècle qu'il
faut juste expliqué que le xvième siècle
et surtout la première moitié et une
période de liberté au fait on alors
exprimé en droit d'écrire la musique
comme on veut surtout le droit de mettre
en musique des textes qui peuvent être
parfois très grivois on en peut mettre
en musique ce qui vous entoure le chant
des oiseaux et clément janequin est un
compositeur qui a réussi à faire la
synthèse de tous les courants musicaux
l'époque en mai tandis que des choses
qui sont extrêmement colorés du madrigal
polyphonique mise en musique de la
commedia dell'arte associant tous les
arts l'ensemble janica a souhaité
moderniser et théâtralisée la mise en
scène du spectacle pour que celle ci
reste compréhensible car à l'époque le
principe du concert n'existe pas on a
prit pars tu fais dans le tous les
instruments et d'épurer au maximum la
polyphonie pour que chaque personnage
garde son identité
des fois on s'amuse à imiter les
instruments pour l'heure pour
accompagner les personnages mais donc il
ya six chanteurs la des six personnages
pour le soir tu comprends son ami est un
opéra interprété en vénitien du 16e
siècle totalement a cappella sur scène
six hommes façon marx brothers
alternant rôle féminin et masculin car à
l'époque peu de femmes étaient autorisés
à vivre de la maison ce que j'ai essayé
moi donc là
le construire c'est une histoire à
partir de madrigaux différents voilà
donc le défi était effectivement d'avoir
une histoire qui se tiennent qui est
chanté en italien mais qu'en même temps
que le public français pouvait
comprendre du début jusqu'à la fin
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est très
visuel aussi ses prêts c'est très
burlesque c'est prêt ça bouge beaucoup
en seconde c'était que visuellement ça
puisse le faire pour découvrir cette
création artistique burlesque et très
visuel avec le célèbre eau contre ténor
dominique visse rendez-vous à la merise
de trappes
j'en finis plus adjoint au maire chargé
de la culture de la ville de bois d'arcy
vient de nous rejoindre en plateau
bonsoir bonsoir
alors jean philippe plus vous venez nous
présenter le lancement du festival le b
à ba
la bande-annonce à bois d'arcy qui aura
lieu samedi soir au cinéma de la grange
à partir de 19h30 alors on sait que la
ville de wallers y avait par le passé un
festival de cinéma qui a été arrêté
pourquoi cette volonté de reprendre avec
un festival de la bande annonce alors
absolument c'est une c'est une première
pour nous on a faim depuis nous sommes
arrivés il ya en mars 2014
à la tête de la commune de bonnard si on
a repensé revu la politique culturelle
notamment la politique cinématographique
comme vous l'avez dit un festival
mémoire des toiles qui avait lieu tous
les ans sur une dizaine de jours au
festival thématique qui était un
festival thématique mais problème le
problème social était trop élitiste et
un peu vieillissant et donc on a voulu
repenser l'intégralité de cette
politique cinématographique en dandy
coupant différents temps dans différents
cours de la saison culturelle avec une
programmation était ce qu'on avait fait
cet été dessinés thé ou le cinéma p r
avec le partenariat du conseil
départemental mais aussi à chaque
événement de l'année une diffusion en
lien à une fusion de films en lien avec
ces grands événements
voyez les événements sportifs ou les
éléments liés aux novembre 8 mai mais
aussi les mardis du cinéma qui commence
depuis la rentrée et surtout ce festival
de la bande annonce que nous que nous
lançons à partir du donc de samedi qui
sera la première édition
pourquoi la bande-annonce parce qu'en
fait la bande annonce c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas traitée ou très peu traité au
niveau national il n'existe pas de
festival sur cette thématique là est ce
une thématique assez important puisqu'en
fait sans la bande annonce on n'a pas
forcément envie d'aller au cinéma c'est
c'est le premier pas vers le film c'est
ce qui nous attire qui nous donne envie
ou pas d'y aller
donc on avait envie de traiter ce genre
à part entière parce qu'en effet il ya
un vrai travail au delà du film pour
prélever préparer cette bande annonce et
faire que
on va diffuser telle ou telle bande
annonce alors le nom du festival
vraiment à l'image selon vous de
l'importance de la bande annonce dans
l'industrie cinématographique c'est
vraiment l'essentiel le béaba exactement
alors c'est un jeu de mots aussi avec le
lit le fait que ce bande annonce à voir
si mais c'est aussi en effet le béaba
puisque c'est le point de départ d'un
film sans cette bande annonce sans se
met à bas les gens n'iraient pas à la
projection cinématographique donc c'est
c'est un nom totalement bien trouvé et
c'est vrai qu'on voit pas ce que lorsque
certaines bandes annonces en fait
divulguer trop le film le film est un
flop est au contraire c'est la
bande-annonce est bien fait ça peut
engendrer le succès du film et on le
voit d'ailleurs avec les boîtes de
production qui externalisent le service
de la production les bandes annonces
c'est exactement ça à syrte c'est un
vrai métier et c'est tout l'intérêt de
la présence si on est ravis on encore
version d'un prêt de vincent perrot qui
va nous décrypter les bandes annonces
il faut savoir attirer sont tous dire
ceci on va au cinéma et qu'on a tous vu
la bande annonce on a un arrière-goût de
je me suis ennuyé donc c'est la vraie
problématique et à plein de choses qu'on
va décrypter lors de cette soirée pour
expliquer aux gens l'intérêt de la bande
annonce et comment elle est construite
c'est également les archives du cnc
centre national de cinématographie
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir un rôle
particulier au sein de ce festival ou
pas alors ils ont un rôle particulier
ils travaillent avec nous sur le
festival aussi sur les mardis du cinéma
et on a la chance avec eux de diffuser
la première bande annonce française on
en dit pas plus mais c'était la première
bande annonce qui a été faite à l'époque
donc 10 913 je crois ou un peu plus amer
c'est très très anciens et donc on a la
chance de points la diffuser grâce au
cnc donc vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un festival qui va être présentée
par vincent perrot
il y aura une quarantaine de bandes
annonces qui seront présentés rangés par
ordre thématique pendant deux heures
dont vous ouvrez à partir de 19h30 et
pourquoi alors votre choix s'est porté
sur vincent perrot est ce qu'il ya une
raison particulière
oui clairement c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant quand on quand on regarde comme
ça on se dit mais dans son perron en
souffrance et des grossesses et les
voitures et à lorsque pas du tout fin
évidemment c'est ça qu'on le connaît
pour ça mais c'est aussi un très très
grand cinéphile et il fait plus qu'animé
la soirée c'est qu'il a énormément
travaillé avec mon en amont sur la
préparation de cette de cette cet
événement
et la très grande majorité pour pas dire
l'intégralité des bandes annonces
viennent de son vivier personnel il dit
pau dispose de plus d'une centaine de
monde annonce et il a travaillé avec
nous sur la constitution du déroulé sur
sur les différents bande annonce qui va
être proposé les thématiques les
organiser et le décryptage
donc c'est un vrai cinéphile qui va
pouvoir apporter énormément cette soirée
et faire vivre cette soirée pour que
toutes les personnes qui sont présentes
samedi soir puisse apprendre un maximum
et du coup à chaque bande annonce il
aura une petite anecdote il expliquera
pourquoi est ce que c'est une bonne
bande annonce pourquoi une mauvaise et
ce qui s'en est suivie pour le succès ou
l'échec du film
alors comme vous l'avez dit à une
quarantaine de bande annonce on comprend
pas le faire est là chaque bonne annonce
par contre en effet sur certaines puces
à chaque thématique
il interviendra pour décrypter la
bande-annonce expliquer comment elle a
été construite pour quoi elles étaient
construites sous cet angle là et ce qui
fait qu'elle est une bonne annonce ou
pas très bien et bien coûter rendez vous
le samedi 7 novembre au cinéma de la
grange de bois d'arcy à partir de 19h30
pour le festival de la bande annonce
jean-philippe plus merci d'avoir été
avec mo en plateau on poursuit toujours
dans le cinéma avec notre rubrique
cinéphiles qu'avez vous pensé des
sorties de ce mercredi 4 novembre vos
avis au micro de camille lambert
c'est un film qui a été repris un thème
qui a été repris des tas de fois et là
nous avons fui autre chose j'ai trouvé
ça génial ça m'a beaucoup plu
c'est le times et l'exode mais ce qui me
met vraiment en plus c'est une histoire
entre le père et le fils et c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas été traité par
ailleurs et c'est vraiment un très bon
film j'ai tardy c'est très bien c'est
toujours très bien ce qui fait très
agréable les vois tu sais très
intéressante table ange laroche lors
très drôle j'avais déjà vu de films de
cuisine aussi mais j'vais c'est un truc
américaine c'est à dire qu'ils savent
faire mais comment dire les cuisiniers
ils vont dévorer sunna je pense c'était
assez représentatifs de la cuisine et du
milieu donc voilà on a apprécié il ya de
l'humour gars de la tendresse
il ya de l'émotion dans saint-henri et
des répliques qui sont trop l'amusante
et malgré tout ça reste un film très
sensible et plein d'émotion ce film m'a
beaucoup plu et je veux en profiter pour
leur commander plusieurs personnes parce
que vraiment il est remarquable
cette semaine c'est bertrand pin et du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr
l'école qui nous donne son coup de coeur
sur les films à l'affiché cette semaine
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa le coup de
coeur cette inculture du mois c'est le
mois du film documentaire le mois de
novembre
et du coup on vous a programmé plein de
documentaires mais en particulier un qui
nous tenait à coeur
un film qui s'appelle compostelle le
chemin de la vie de
freddy mouchard compostelle le chemin de
la vie c'est un film que nous
proposerons pendant quatre semaines
pendant le mois du film documentaire
mais aussi qui est important pour nous
parce que nous recevons le réalisateur
ce vendredi 6 novembre à 20h30
c'est un film qui vous parlera du chemin
de compostelle évidemment comme son nom
l'indiqué mais pas du tout comme un
chemin de prière ou comme un chemin
religieux il vous en parlera comme un
chemin spirituel
c'est un très très beau film qui
s'appuie vraiment sur les paysages sur
le trajet sur la longueur du trajet du
chemin de compostelle sur les preuves
physiques que ça peut représenter sans
jamais s'attarder trop sur des parcours
de personnes d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
vraiment d'acteur dans ce film le chemin
est le seul acteur puisqu'en fait tout
les randonneurs qui sont partie prenante
du film ne sont là qu'en voix off ne
sont que qu'entendu et jamais filmés et
ça donne un film très très beau du coup
très profond sur la spiritualité
associés aux chemins de compostelle mais
aussi et surtout sur la randonnée et sur
le fait de marcher et sur ce que ça
provoque autant intérieurement que
psychologiquement fin physiquement que
psychologiquement
voilà c'est donc un vrai vraiment une
très belle découverte
à découvrir tout au long du mois de
novembre
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et en
particulier le vendredi 6 novembre en
présence du réalisateur freddy mouchard
en espérant vous retrouver très nombreux
et bientôt merci et maintenant retour
sur notre plateau avec vladimir steyer
qui vient de nous rejoindre pour
assistant metteur en scène de notre peur
de n'être au côté de fabrice murgia qui
va nous décrypter la mise en scène de la
pièce vladimir steyer bonsoir soir alors
je le disais notre peur de n'être en
fait c'est une pièce qui a été
représentée hier au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça s'est bien
passé
oui très bien la salle était pleine
voilà plus de 800 personnes
la danse est superbe théâtre où google
est très heureux voilà cette
représentation est ce que le succès de
cette pièce justement tient à la mise en
scène et la scénographie vraiment qu'il
ya qui est marquée de l'empreinte de
fabrice mon cher oui je pense qu'en tout
cas il ya quelque chose de très atypique
dans l'univers scénique de fabrice
murgia qui met en scène du coup la vidéo
comme un élément à part entière du ce
est vraiment plus de la vidéo le théâtre
le son la lumière
oui voilà il ya vraiment quelque chose
va qui mélangent toutes ces disciplines
au service voilà d'une histoire parce
que notre peur de n'être ce avant tout
une histoire sur notre monde
contemporain
fabrice amour j on le rappelle juste qui
a eu le lion d'or en 2014 à la biennale
de venise
alors justement cette fabrice auger qui
est aussi un habitué du questionnement
des problématiques générationnel cette
fois ci a cherché à interroger la
solitude de l'homme moderne à l'ère du
virtuel qu'est ce qu'il entend par là
alors quelque chose qui frappe beaucoup
fabrice c'est quand il est en train
quand il voit quand il passe la nuit
devant des des immeubles il voit là des
petites bulles de chaque fenêtre et où
il se dit maintient qu est ce qui se
raconte comme histoire individuelle
derrière chaque chaque fenêtre et donc
il a décidé de mettre en avant la 4e'
stuard pour ce spectacle et donc chacune
caractéristiques d'un archétype de la
solitude contemporaine
donc on a aussi bien quelqu'un qui fait
face à une solitude lié à une des traces
amoureuse que quelqu'un qui s'enferme
compte
vêtements chez lui là en passant par une
solitude vie y est du coup vraiment à
l'opposé à un trop plein d'activités
pour combler un vide existentiel il ya
un autre personnage aussi qui a une
solitude liée à une forme d'immigration
des gens qui sont unis grèce se retrouve
un peu en marge de la société et s'est
également inspiré du phénomène japonais
hikikomori alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ce phénomène
alors l'équipe komori donc c'est un mot
japonais qui veut dire vivre replié sur
soi et donc c'est un phénomène qui
existe depuis une quinzaine d'années
d'abord au japon mais qui arrive de plus
en plus en france et donc cédé des
jeunes gens d'une vingtaine d'années qui
décident de vivre repliés sur eux-mêmes
dans leur chambre et donc qu'il se coupe
complètement du monde extérieur qui
limite tout le contact qui peuvent avoir
deux avec d'autres humains donc s'ils
ont besoin d'aller s'acheter à manger
ces sortes de nuit pour aller à des
distributeurs ou sinon ils se font
livrer chez eux
voilà tout ce qui est voit la nourriture
ou un produit de première nécessité
donc c'est un vrai choix en fait un
choix de vie c'est quelque chose voilà
qu'on sait pas trop voilà il ya certains
psychologues qui parle de pathologie
sociale comme c'est quelque chose qui
est très récent il ya très peu d'études
là qui permettent d'avoir voilà du recul
réel sur ça mais on n'ose y voilà entre
quelque chose qui pourrait être de
l'ordre voilà de la pale de la
pathologie l'air sociopathe et de
l'autre qui est un vrai choix
j'irai politique un peu comme les
ermites qui au moyen-âge se retirait du
monde pour aller méditer dans le désert
ou dans une grotte et comment alors on
peut s'interroger comment est ce que
vous avez réussi à mettre en scène cette
solitude elle passe par quoi
alors donc nous on a travaillé sur
plusieurs
un premier temps tout un temps d'un pro
sur différents types de la de solitude
et suite à toutes ses improvisations
faites par les comédiens fabrice a écrit
différents scénarios alors fabrice voilà
il a un univers avec beaucoup de vidéos
ils travaillent en fait sous forme de
storyboards commun comme un réalisateur
de cinéma c'est pas du tout un auteur de
théâtre dit classique avec acte 1 scène
1 s'est créé différentes scènes voilà
souvent d'après des images très fortes
et ensuite il les remet à laax
différemment comme un monteur au cinéma
mais vraiment pour exprimer la solitude
en fait cette solitude elle passe par la
mise en scène d'une interface à chaque
fois entre le comédien et sa pathologie
on va dire où son rapport à la société
donc je crois qu'il ya un dictaphone
pour l'un de vos personnages il ya un
téléphone portable également donc c'est
vraiment la critique du numérique qui
forme un écran entre la société
et est il humain on va dire alors tout
cas je sais pas si c'est une critique
mais en tout cas c'est un constat
qu'aujourd'hui quelque chose de très
paradoxale qui est qu'on est de plus en
plus connectés voilà grâce aux nouvelles
technologies via skype qui peut nous
permettre de parler avec quelqu'un
l'autre bout du monde et qu'en même
temps on est de plus en plus seul et le
constat voilà qui est très frappant
c'est on est dans le bus dans le métro
et tout le monde est derrière son écran
de téléphone et même aujourd'hui voilà
on voit des couples au restaurant qui au
lieu de se parler en tête à tête maya
toujours à la entre eux ce filtre qui
est le téléphone portable smartphone
et donc voilà c'était comment dire
c'était une réflexion sur comment voilà
ces accessoires liés au nouveau monde
peuvent être un frein
simplement une création de communautés
humaines et on va le revoir d'ailleurs à
l'image on voit vraiment que sur la
scénographie vous avez cherchait en fait
à créer un cadre fluorescents tout
autour pour qu'on ait l'impression
d'avoir comme être face à un écran un
écran de 2 photos ou un écran de cinéma
nous voilà totalement aulas sait où ça
peut être aussi l'écran d'ordinateur et
donc voilà ce cadre de scène la lumineux
sur lequel volant on projette également
voilà beaucoup de vidéos est aussi un
filtre entre ce qui se passe sur la
scène et ce que ressentent
voilà les spectateurs comme si on avait
toujours des empêchements dans notre
société pour être pleinement avec les
autres alors cette critique de la
conceptualisations numérique du futur
n'est pas négatif parce que je sais que
pour fabrice mangeait derrière se cache
un message d'espoir pour peut-être fait
renaître justement une contre-culture
vladimir steyer merci d'avoir été reçus
heures en plateau pour nous décrypter
notre peur de n'être et avant de se
quitter je vous propose maintenant
quelques dates culturel à noter dans vos
agendas
vendredi 6 novembre à 19 heures 30 à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux pour
rien ne se perd avec le collectif de la
boue est une comédie absurde et 100%
récup
le défi monter un spectacle à empreinte
carbone zéro résultat un texte hilarant
et absurde
la première fois courteline répond à
shakespeare extraits bonsoir on s'est
lancé un défi faire un spectacle à
empreinte carbone zéro alors on récupère
on rafistole on recycle les cuillères en
plastique les pots de yaourts les
papiers journaux où elle a également
fait les rédacteurs et surtout les
auteurs vous êtes venus écouter une
histoire là retombe vous servir le
meilleur du rocambolesque de l'amour du
sens du rire du suspense des petits
oiseaux et les jolis mots surtout des
jolis mots samedi 7 novembre à 18 heures
à la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt pour
angels in america
une grande fresque des années quatre
vingts made in usa une peinture au
vitriol de la société au dialogue
fulgurant avec un souffle d'enfer et
enfin je vous propose dimanche 8
novembre à 17 heures de retrouver
l'ensemble ce travail kenza pour un
concert de musique classique au coeur de
port royal des champs sonnette à 2
violon viole de gambe et basse continue
fin du kiosque pour cette semaine
l'émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet très bonne soirée à tous